and interchange known for crashes and
backups getting a much needed makeover
it runs from gallery and drive to
Horizon Drive along the i-11 and on 215
from Valley Verde Drive to Lake Mead
Parkway 8 news now reporter Brian Whelan
shows us how it will impact drivers
this interchange here behind me in
Henderson has been subject to congestion
after years of growth here in the valley
but a new project is hoping to improve
the traffic flow and safety for those
that use it this will ease that
congestion give alternative routes for
them to take and make it so that there
are less risky Maneuvers happening this
350 million dollar project will make
improvements on the roads you see here
eliminating a lack of roadways and
improving traffic connectivity
on Wednesday congresswoman Susie Lee
presented five million dollars from the
community housing fund to help with the
project this is an interchange that was
built 17 years ago over half a million
people have moved into the valley we
know it's used by people coming into the
valley from Arizona the rest of the
money will come from other local state
and federal funds money the city of
Henderson is still working to secure
you'll start to notice orange cones
going up in 2024 and once complete the
inter change will be converted to this
crossover style interchange what's
really important to us in this project
and part of the design build selection
is that they maintain the traffic flow
for us and they maintain good
connectivity while they're building the
project the project is still in the
preliminary design phase with completion
not expected until about 2026. reporting
in Henderson Brian will 8 News Now
now the project is set to move into the
final design stage this year with
construction starting by the end of
2024.